we did a survey about two years ago when
they just launched anti-corruption
campaign
everyone thought it's going to be
short-lived but it's not it's been two
years now and it's still deepening and
reaching all sectors in the economy
originally we saw it's going to be just
a purge in the military in the
government now it seems like effects
pretty much you know corporates in all
sectors and in change the groups as well
we look at that Swiss watch because
those stocks have been driven primarily
by its growth in China you know the
owner of Omega the owner of Rolex
however after the survey we realized
that 60% and above of the purchases was
driven by gifting so not only to you
know purchase the pieman to their
mistresses and also can be purchased by
business people for their you know
related true for their contacts business
contacts and the business part of the
partners and government officials to a
degree that macau casino has an element
of that as well
especially in in the VIP rooms so what's
good about this anti-corruption is I
think the current leadership by doing so
they are really kind of restoring some
confidence domestically may people
realize that inappropriate behaviors in
the government abused by government
officials and you know in the business
world is no longer acceptable so part of
the gifting economy is moving
underground and part of is just start
away so and going forward I think we
will see more contraction in luxury
cells not only just the bags and the
Swiss watches but also we'll continue to
see that in Macau VIP rooms luxury autos
luxury bank banquets luxury outings
so that would to a degree affect you
know five five star hotels in China
expensive restaurants in China as well
so that's you know if if you go to any
sort of conferences right now I mean
that's a really heated topic everyone
trying to gauge the magnitude of this
campaign and how long it's going to last
I just got back from Beijing from a trip
so I took a group of investors in the
u.s. to me with the policy makers and
policy advisors to the leadership in
Beijing and the takeaway is it's not as
superficial as people think it's going
to be there for a while and it seems
like you know the current leaders are
very committed to purge corruptions and
drop corrupted behaviors